ما حقيقه الضجه التي اثيرت حول تصريحات
ميشيل اليو ماري الوزيره الفرنسيه الشهيره
في تلك الفتره
وعلاقتها بالسلطه التونسيه انا ذاك فرنسيه
طبعا
معدات الامنيه لقاء مع التظاهرات
هو احنا تونس من مزودين
في في هذه الاشياء هي فرنسا بتالي الاتصال
بهمه او طلب ااا كيف يسموها يعني
حاجه عاديه جدا
في ملاعب كره القدم
في في في ملاعب كره القدم
يستهلك فيها الله كريم
بمساعده قوى الامن التونسيه بارسال قنابل
مسيره للدموع والى ما هنالك للمساهمه في
خدمات الثورات خاصه الموقع
[موسيقى]
خل الاتصال بامكان ليه في اطار العلاقات
الثنائيه وكان اكثر ولا اقل هو ذلك
التصريح وهو يهمه السيد كمال مرجان تحدثها
في هذا البرنامج
تطوير العلاقات
في تلك الفتره وفي تلك الفتره كانت عاديه
في مستوى عادي جدا همم
[موسيقى]
ليس فيها التوتر
لانه العلاقات مع الولايات المتحده كانت
في امور معينه خاصه
ومعروفه على العلاقه مع فرنسا ايضا بسيط
طاهر العلاقه مع الولايات المتحده انا باك
اثارتها او اثارت اشكالتها مساله ويكيليكس
احدثت ما اكثر مضايا الرئيسي في ويكيليكس
همم
عند تاشيره يعني اشياء خاصه همم مذكرات
سفيره ومراسلات سفيره الى اخيره هذه
الطبيعه الحال تثير عده اشياء وتغضب
اعطينا مثلا على امر
بالظبط
[موسيقى]
يعني ذكرت فيها اشياء حتى
استهلك في عشاء وفي المهد يعني ولم نتعود
هذا في العلاقات الدوليه
ولكن في العلاقات الدوليه ايضا همم نعرف
ان الولايات المتحده لم تهنئ الرئيس
التونسي على اعاده انتبهابه هذا لا اعرف
عنه كمال
على وزير الخارجيه الاسبقس كمان المرجان
واجبكم على هذا لان انا لا اعرف
دوائر القصر يوميا
التهاني جي من عده اطراف
ولست انا من يتابع من هنا ومن لم ولكن
يمكن ان تتلمس اذا ما كان الرئيس
المتحده الامريكيه
بعد الانتخابات وبعد مباشره او بعد معنا
في
نوفمبرت حكايه ويكيليكس
لا ادري